you reached the cause from home show
would you like to leave a shout out
tonight
deep in the heart of the appalachian
mountains an unlikely ally is helping
families to connect with their loved
ones serving time in nearby maximum
security
prisons alrighty that last one was keith
sweat
i'm elizabeth sanders the general
manager of wmmt which is the community
radio station of apple shop based in
whitesburg kentucky
over the past 20 years the prison
industry in appalachia has grown
exponentially now housing thousands of
prisoners from all over the united
states
for many living behind bars the show
calls from home is their primary means
of outside communication
just called you say i love you and
hopefully you're doing good out there i
haven't heard from you oh she's going
well with you
calls from home is a way for folks to
call in and leave shout outs for their
loved ones who are locked up in prisons
around here prison phone rates are
really exorbitant or if you're on
lockdown you don't get to use it at all
another thing that makes it really hard
or that the folks that are incarcerated
here their families are really really
far away so this is a way
that they can keep in touch every week
akka is your mom
wishing you a happy birthday hello very
much i know it's stressful sweetheart i
want you to keep your head up and wait
until i get a chance to see you all
different sorts of folks call in it's
everything from friends to mothers to
children
for michelle hudson whose partner
william is serving a life sentence
calls from home helps keep them
connected i've been calling into the
show every monday since 2012
calls from home helps him to just regain
some strength regain his focus
and even put a smile on his face it has
become his eyes to help him see outside
of those walls hearing those shows every
single week helps them hold on helps
them to just get through another day
i think it's easy to forget
that these folks who are in the prison
system around here are actually part of
our community so to not forget them or
their family members that are far away
is really important
that show brings that humanity back it
brings the compassion and love that
they're missing on a daily basis
back to their cell phone hi this message
is going out to my handsome king at
wallins ridge hey what's going on big
grip
it's your love michelle i miss you where
have you been the last couple of days